I was browsing the David Pakman show
subreddit this morning you can find it
at david pakman.com /r EDD IT I'm
expecting in January that we will hit
5,000 subscribers the david pakman show
subreddit great place to meet virtually
meet and discuss politics or whatever
else is on your mind with other David
Pakman show audience members some of the
threads that I found interesting this
morning starting with Ben Shapiro's
anti-abortion argument this has turned
into a really good discussion with over
a hundred comments he's debating and
discussing the merits and failings of an
argument against abortion that a
conservative commentator ben shapiro
made on his program it's actually a
really good thread to read through which
picks apart some of the common anti
choice talking points from the right
also on our subreddit totalitarianism a
post about donald trump's presidency and
some of the sort of totalitarian or i
tend to call the more authoritarian
tendencies yes there is a difference but
there's probably a case to be made that
there is some totally totalitarian ish
stuff that is going on under the trump
administration very interesting
discussion on our subreddit also a
thread about whether donald trump is too
stupid for autocracy i found this
interesting because i've been saying for
a while that donald trump more than
likely if we do eventually find evidence
of russia collusion it was not proactive
collusion it's that donald trump is a
great mark to be manipulated by a
hostile foreign power and i think that
there is the same case to be made that
in some case in some ways trump is too
incompetent for full autocracy the types
of the likes of which some are
suggesting he would want to do he just
doesn't know enough he's not competent
enough it's possible to be a stupid
autocrat what's hard to do is to rise to
power if you're stupid but he was able
to get away with that it was indeed and
we've a Monday Morning Quarterback to
how that happened the number of times we
won't do it again here also from our
subreddit do republicans have no shame
and this is a very good thread pointing
out that we see we seem to see
the continued and relentless attack on
the middle class from the Trump
Republican infrastructure not only
passing a tax bill that is going to be a
tax increase for more than half of all
Americans attacking children's health
insurance attacking all aspects of the
programs that we actually see is
beneficial to the middle class and
lastly I think this is the last one a
thread requesting that people help get
me on the Bill Maher program on HBO it's
Benny I want to be super upfront about
this I would love to be on Real Time
with Bill Maher I that would be a
program that if I appeared on it would
so hugely move the needle for us in a
way that my appearance is on CNN and Fox
News I've never done but it's been years
that off and on people have been
tweeting to Bill Maher and his producers
to have me on I'm not saying don't do it
I just don't know that they want to have
me on well do you think that's spamming
their forum their contact forum would
help could it be counterproductive it
also could be kind of you I've heard
that like with Joe Rogan he doesn't like
people tweeting him saying have this
person on or have that person on I don't
know what the deal is with Bill Maher
and his producers I would love to be on
it would be a major event for the David
Pakman show if I were ever on but I
don't know that they care for one reason
or another to have me on Real Time with
Bill Maher and I think that if you start
doing MMA you can get on Joe Rogan I
don't if I do Ultra ultra supreme
featherweight MMA then maybe the next
thing you know I'll be on Joe Rogan's
podcast that's maybe it may be a project
for 2018 anyway a please become a
subscriber to our subreddit nearly 5,000
if you already have at david pakman.com
slash re d di t